para algunos es solo un paquete de papas
fritas pero este residente de la capital
ucraniana ha estado esperando este
momento durante meses
esa felicidad pura felicidad
mcdonald's había estado cerrado desde el
comienzo de la guerra y recientemente
tres sucursales de la cadena de comida
rápida en kiev han reabierto para
domicilio mientras tanto algunos
clientes comenzaron a hacer sus pedidos
desde el día anterior
creo que no voy a descansar hoy por
favor de algunos clientes incluso
esperaron junto a sus repartidores para
recoger su pedido tan pronto como
estuviera listo la demanda era tan alta
que una aplicación local de entrega de
comida tuvo que cancelar sus pedidos y
dejó de aceptar nuevos para muchos
ucranianos mcdonald's es señal de que la
vida normal está regresando a la ciudad
realmente me gustaría olvidarme de la
guerra y recordar cómo se sentían las
cosas antes de la invasión rusa a gran
escala mcdonald simboliza esa época
anterior a la guerra de ataxias tengo
las desdichas
mcdonald dijo que planea abrir otros
siete restaurantes en kiev el próximo
mes nunca dejó de pagar a sus empleados
en sus más de 100 sucursales ucranianas
a pesar de los cierres pero en rusia el
gigante de la comida rápida vendió sus
operaciones a la empresa multimillonario
alexander govern los más de 800 antiguos
restaurantes ahora han sido rebautizados
como sabroso y punto tienen hamburguesas
y papas fritas pero los equivalentes
rusos del icónico big mac o mcflurry
están fuera del menú